also recke ist die
gamescom
youtube gegriffen
und hier sind ein paar
erfolgreich wie zum beispiel alberto di
gioia
tutorial chemie alles in bar
und muss ich mal wirklich sagen als ich
gedacht habe
von hus
nicht
die spannung steigt auf der vestischen
warten warten warten und albertus war
nicht da kaffeekultur
kleinen ufer aber coco von cosmos schon
gar nicht geben
das war kann ich nicht sagen der mensch
am samstag gibt es davon noch viel mehr
brauchen ich hab es noch 1 2
die stimmung ist riesig ich bin auch
ehrlich gesagt ein wenig überwältigt von
der voranschlag der besucher es freut
uns das ja wie ihr seid dass wir
gemeinsam mit uns die spiele feiert
hinter spielspaß bis sonntag auf der
gamescom
grandios ich freue mich dass ihr alle da
seid
was würdest du
musst dich jetzt
muss sich entschuldigen dafür dass die
gerichte da ist halt erst seit ich
wollte dass länder zu lernen ich wollte
nicht dass das so herkommt und so
verhält das ist eigentlich viel zu tun
angenommen
die auf der treppe
vielen dank christoph kexel organisieren
dieses events heute ist nur besseren
zustande gekommen weil diese youtube.com
juni so stark gefangen hält und was ist
schief ist
also alle die nicht hören ich möchte
mich mal bei allen leuten bedanken das
immer so nett zu mir sein und die videos
coach der kommentar im amt und wirklich
super vielen dank
er findet selbst war toll jetzt sage ich
mal kurz raus weil ich hier so viele
gesichter wer die ich schon mal gesehen
habe weil in frage und vergessen
das finde ich sensationell und jetzt
komm ich
konnte zwei geplatzten vielleicht
gedacht mehr als tausend abonnenten
bekommen aber ja
dass wir das nächste gebäude von wie
macht man eine zufällig an dem paket zu
aber du machst
wir haben die verwertung sehr ist man
halt mit box dass es mir den montag nur
so
sie habe ich auch so sieht
mit
st
ich will
sagen wir finden
den wald